hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the Grantchester it's machine
wash Alegre versus Dingley rain they
will be battling it out to see who takes
first place and before we check out the
game we do have some very nice photos
courtesy of Leonard otice official
photographer of the Grantchester here
the two of them I from yesterday's
Probus Cup there you have it you can see
that they are really enjoying themselves
they they want everything that needed to
be won and now you know they just have
to beat each other to take first place
and you don't really win anything aside
from more money by being first well you
do get the you know honor of being first
but I don't think neither of them are in
it for the money then gives all the
money he wins you know to hit to his
mother and well III think MVL will be
perfectly fine with prize number one or
prize number two money-wise so I think
both of them are here just to enjoy
themselves and to play some good chess
so here we have our nice photo of this
young gentleman making the first move
for Maxime even though he played see for
Maxime did not enjoy see for so he
played something else and here we have
another young gentleman making the first
move for being replying to the first
gentleman's move by playing c5 so the
two of them did not enjoy the English so
instead Maxime opened with e4 you
sometimes you know the when someone
older is making a move for the player
they will ask them do you want to play
this move and then they will say yeah
I'm gonna play this one and they played
that move but obviously when children do
it they just play a move and then if the
players don't like it they do something
else or if you're worried harrelson then
Caruana will tell you which movie you
carvanha wants to play and then woody
will make a different move just to make
it a funny moment so there's that but
yeah Maxime opens with E for now with E
5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop
to b5 a nice rule opus game and well I
forgot to mention if you fail to see my
previous video the subscribers video
2020 will be in the making so make sure
you're a part of it you know more more
about that in the description below and
well more more more about that in the
previous video which will also be in the
description below so more fees defense
with a 6 more
defensive bishop 2a4 Knight to f6 and
now castles we have Bishop to e7 biting
d3 and b5 so all fairly standard stuff
Bishop to b3 we have d6 a3 and now being
castles we have Knights 2 C 3 and here
Knights the a5 ding is following a game
he already played against the Magnus
Carlsen in the 2017 championship
showdown where Carson defeated ding but
in that match and Magnus just massacred
the ding I think that's that that's when
ding really grew as a player but Bishop
to a2 and now Bishop to e6 countering
the DA to Bishop we have B for Bishop
captures a native rook captures a native
and now tonight back to c6 so everything
the same as in the game Carlsen versus
ding in 2017 so Bishop to g5 with Queen
to d7 connecting rules developing the
Queen and now freeing the d5 square for
the White Knight Bishop captures on f6
now with Bishop characters and now
Knight to d5 which is a beautiful square
for the knight if you want to kick it
away then you're gonna go Knight to e7
but then white will just gobble up in
the bishop on f6 or or maybe not so we
have a 5 still everything the same as in
the game Carlsen ding we have c4 ding
repeats his move as he played against
Carson Knights the e7 and this is where
the game takes a different turn here
didn't play the rook the c2 in the game
he lost against well Magnus played rook
to c2 in the game he lost against in the
game he won won against ding in 2017 but
maxeen goes Queen to b3 and Queen to b3
is a new move so already as a move 17 we
have a completely new game so let's see
what maxime prepared and it's very very
likely that well of course he knew about
that game that ding lost as there aren't
all that many games that ding lost we
have big characters on c4 biding Knight
captures on e7 with check first Bishop
captures on e7 and now D captures on c4
saying that okay you have a bishop but
my knight will be stronger as it is
somewhat of a closed position and all of
your pawns are on dark squares with a
cat person before a capture somebody
four and now Queen to see six biding
attacking the e4 pawn rook to e1
defending and the now teeing traits with
rook captures Queen captures and the now
comes rook the a8 pushing the Queen back
Queen to b3 and now g6 making a room for
the king so you don't have to worry
about any back ranked weaknesses we have
b5 by Maxine at Queen to c5 and now
comes Queen to c2 so keeping an eye on
all the points and now the rook can move
you don't have to keep an eye on the e4
pawn with the rook and here I think can
choose a few moves for example rook to
a3 it's a nice idea activating the rook
maybe then putting the Queen behind the
rook so maybe you can even go to a two
with the rook but the move I the moving
plate is much more enjoyable as that we
already mentioned that this is a passive
Bishop all of his bones around dark
square so here ding just gives up a pawn
and freeze this diagonal for his Bishop
so Maxim captures it and now just a
bishop to d8 he's now gonna go to b6 and
put pressure on the f2 pawn
we have Knights the d2 by Maxine Bishop
to b6 now threatening Queen captures on
f2 and now Knight to b3 attacking the
Queen and only now does ding recapture
on c6 we have looked look to a-1
offering a rook trade but now rook the
c8 now again going after the c4 pawn we
have looked a c1 defending and now h5
with h4 maxime also makes an escape
route for the King if needed and now
rook back to a 8 you are not winning
this e4 pawn so now you want to get some
activity for a look back the a1 of
course
maxime will not giving the open a file
rook character Sunday one we have Knight
captures anyone and now Queen to d7
Queen to d7 the Queen is a very very
useful there you can go to g4 from there
you can attack a lot of points
so after g3 we have g5 by dink and here
the problem with capturing for example
on g5 is Queen to h3 it's really it's
it's a really powerful move and white
will have to play very passive moves
because Queen captures on g3 is a huge
threat since the f2 point is
pinned so here first Queen to d2
threatening Queen g5 check we have G
captures on h4 and now comes the moment
from the thumbnail which I really
enjoyed the problem now with Queen Queen
to g5 check King f8 and Queen recaptures
on h4 which was a Maxim's idea is Quinta
a for Andalusia because well the knight
is trapped you you cannot save the night
all of these squares are covered and
well there are no useful moves for white
so here the move Maxime played and why I
used it in the thumbnail is because it's
just beautiful c5 because the D pawn is
pinned
you cannot capture since you lose the
Queen Maxime the thing has to play
Bishop captures on c5 and now the same
idea works now magazine goes Queen g5
check King to f8 and only now Queen
captures on h4 where it's not the same
now Queen to a4 doesn't win for ding yes
the knight is trapped but the bishop is
no longer on b6 so you don't control the
d8 square so here at Queen d8 check and
you will be able to use this diagonal to
deliver perpetual check scheme to g7
Queen goes through back to g5 check and
if the King goes back you just repeat
and if not for example after Queen to d8
sure you can even just go night the
after King g7 you can even go Knight to
b3 and now if the knight is captured
otherwise you're just gonna bring it
back into the game now just or you can
also go Queen g5 checking if 7 you can
capture here King g8 Queen g5 and you
will constantly be using this diagonal
to deliver perpetual checks and the
black will be unable to and get out of
them so after Queen captures on h4
dink had the option of going Queen to g4
it basically trades down into this
endgame our wording has to decide
whether he can take take out
maxime in this endgame bishop against
tonight being up a pawn because if you
don't trade queens for example if you
try something else Queen to d8 check
Queen g7 it's now gonna be very
difficult because well there's the
threat of Queen d1 check picking up the
night and also there's just the threat
of Queen Catherine g3 as the F pawn is
still pinned so the anything other than
trading Queens here would just lose so
Queen to G
or was a definitely a good option for
ding but he first goes king dat now he
guards this square with the king and now
he's threatening Queen to a for so night
the b3 now threatening the either
capture or just bring the knight into
the game and the now comes Queen to a4
and the now comes the moment where
Maxime really has to be careful it's
it's a really tough position for him so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the best way for Maxime to continue
this game while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on finding such
a such an impressive defensive idea and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
Maxime play tonight captures on c5 but
best is Queen to h3 and now it's it's
just controlling much more irrelevant
squares now Quinta c8 is also an idea
and now if you continue with Queen
captures nb3 Quinta ch-check allows you
the perpetual because the pawn here is
guarding these two squares and you will
not be able to escape with the king king
e7 Queen c7 check King e6 now you're
just gonna go up Queen c7 Quincy eight
checking if six Queen to d8 checking to
g6 but now Queen to g8 check king of six
you're gonna repeat and if you go back
then Queen g5 check and a week once
again control this diagonal and we can
deliver perpetual checks but Maxine when
tonight captures on c5 and now he goes
into the most unpleasant end game where
ding is up upon but also it's a very
strong past C pawn so Queen captures on
h5 equalizing in points but now Queen
captures on e4 we have Queen - a trade
check King to e7 and now comes Queen to
see it so here
Maxine has to do everything in his power
to not lose this game as he's down upon
and it's a very fast past pawn so he
will either have to create some sort of
a perpetual idea or hope that the ding
blunders
so Queen to d4 centralizing the Queen
now preparing to start pushing the C
pawn we have g4 by Maxine c4 by ding
with g5 by Maxine c3 binding and now
King to g2 not allowing any Queen d1
checks and then just promoting the pawn
all the way with King to d6 now starting
at get to the king into the game Queenie
fourth check was also possible as you
wouldn't gain control of the c2 square
but this will now just show you how
incredibly difficult the Queen end games
are we have f3 preventing e4 even though
e for it is definitely playable here if
white captures you just capture with
check and then again you have control of
the C 2 square we have Queen to d2 check
by ding King h3 and now of course I hope
none of you are considering c2 now
because that just loses Queen d8 check
you move and then you pick up the Queen
and control the queening square like
that
so after Queen h3 with Queen King to d5
wedding and now Queen to f5 so what do
you do here King back to c6
you could try pushing c2 but it's it's
much too soon because Queen d7 again
picks up the Queen and again you guard
this so you have to be careful so King
back to c6 guarding the d7 square but
now Queen back to CH check we've kinked
d6 Queen to f8 check kink the c6 and
queen to ca to check and now Dean
finally starts going down the board we
have Queen - b7 check came to c5 and now
Queen to a7 check and here for for some
reason being didn't go King - before it
does does he does have to allow Queen
captures here and then just Queen
captures and g5 and now both ones are
guarded now you're just gonna bring the
King slowly down the board and put this
pawn
although okay this is much easier said
than done the White Queen has like a
million checks you have to [ __ ] it it's
impossible to calculate then you just
have to you know know which which way is
the correct way so ding decided to go
back came to these six but now Queen b8
check we have kicked the d5 now Queen
the b7 check King to d4 now Queen the
efore check here ding parts with one of
the pawns King c5 Queen captures with
check and now King to c4 ding gives up
upon to try and get more activity with
the king queen e4 check King B 3 but now
Queen to be one with check King a3 we
have Queen to a one with check and now
King to be four with
in to be one with check and now king to
see five and now there are no more
checks
other than useful checks other than
Queen to f5 which Maxine goes for but
now ding is able to block with the Queen
we have Queen to c8 check now comes King
to d4 Queen to g4 check King to d3 and
now there really are no more useful
checks so Maxine plays g6 and it's
another incredibly resourceful move by
Maxine and here ding really started
thinking and he really started wasting
time and he wasted almost all of his
time he went down to like one minute and
well I'm not gonna tell you what being
played but feel free to pause the video
and try to find a figure out what you
would play here if you if you had black
pieces well I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations it's
definitely not an easy move to find and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
the move to play is f captures and g6
and everyone was like ding did not play
this didn't continue with c2 and
everyone was like how come didn't ding
didn't see it you know the engines are
just screaming F captors and g6 the
problem is F characters and g6 is not
you know a straightforward thing to see
for example after Queen captures on g6
check you're gonna have to go to D to
Queen G to check King to c1 and again
you will have to allow so many checks
check King to see two you're gonna go
Queen F to check King and now you can
lock with the Queen Queen d2 now Queen
to b6 not allowing the King to escape so
you can start pushing your C pawn and
now the point is you have to go King be
three Queen the g6 check King to e3 and
now you have two after Queen g1 check
pick up the f3 pawn and this way you
remove everything from the board and you
just you're just left with this one
point and then you have to know that
this is winning after another million
checks that the White Queen delivers you
will have to hide somewhere block some
checks with the Queen and then start
advancing your your C pawn so even
though if you put this position to an
engine of course the engine is you know
filled with the table bases he will just
scream yes of course the G captures F
captures and g6 is winning but for a
human it's not all that
simple f5 also a very hard very very
difficult move to calculate Queen a4 and
now again what do you play here Queen to
a6 if you go after the pond just g7 and
if c2 now you get g8 Queen and after
Queen captures and GA to get Queen
captures on a5 way to check and again
black and now the black queen is too far
away to for the black king to hide from
all the checks and also defended the c2
point so here being played the c2 he was
already down to one minute and something
and well probably he miscalculated mate
because here maxime play the G captures
on f7 Bing continued c1 Queen and the
maxime also played f8 Queen and here
being played Quinta h1 check King to g3
and Queen to e5 check and this is the
problem and this is something that
happens to a lot of people calculating
games where there are two queens on the
board is extremely hard as if you just
seen where our 4 Queens on the board I
don't think it's possible for a human so
here if Queen blocks with Queen to f4
then you have just Queen to e1 and now
it's mate ok the Queen covers everything
and this Queen delivers check so this is
made problem is
maxime shows blocked with the other
Queen and this is probably something
doing missed during his calculation and
now there is no mermaid so then
continued Queen g1 check King gauge for
Queen to h1 check King g3 Queen e2 e1
with check King to g4 Queen H to H for
check King to f5 now Queen to h5 check
King to f6 and now Quinta a one with
check and it's really weird formation
and you might think that ok there must
be made somewhere in there but there
isn't so King e6 by Maxine Queen 280
check
I didn't tries to go do some lettering
with the Queen Queen B - checking e6
Queen b3 check King goes back Queen back
the b2 with check Queen c3 check doesn't
help because you're not reaching the sea
Foursquare King e6 Queen b3 check King
f6 Queen c3 check now King to e6 and now
you can just repeat moves here as you
don't have any more useful checks if you
go here then e
the Queen's can block it's not a problem
so queen g6 check but now that Queen 4
to f6 just blocks if you play this Queen
then okay here black is winning after
Queen to c6 check because you don't have
where you're gonna lose one of the
Queen's it either that or get made it so
Queen the c5 check you're gonna go came
back to e6 and now Queen to eat check
wins because the King has nowhere to go
you're gonna have to block and then just
Queen captures will be made so here of
course Maxime doesn't make that mistake
he was queen 4 to f6 blocks we have
Queen to c6 check but now King to e7
this move saves Maxime Queen c5 checking
the e6 Queen to c6 check King to e7
Queen to c7 with check King to e6 now
Queen b6 check King to e7 and our Queen
c5 check so exploiting all of the
options maybe hoping that Maxine will
blunder something King e6 Queen Sita f5
now with check of course you cannot
capture here King to e7 ending just
played Queen to c5 check and it was in
this position that the players agreed to
a draw if you wanted to force a draw you
could either you could also just trade
Queens for example captures captures
captures captures and play King here and
you will grab this point either if the
King moves or reported upon doesn't
really matter it will be a draw by
insufficient materials you could also
draw it by force but ding prefers Queen
to c5 check and I like I said it was in
this position on mu 90 that the players
agreed to a draw so really impressive
stuff adding basically created something
out of nothing with the black pieces
MVL had that opportunity to play Queen
h3 but it was a really complicated
position and ding really really created
something out of nothing but this just
shows you how incredibly complicated the
Queen and ponen games are really just
insane stuff is it's impossible to
calculate okay if ding didn't find it
then I mean who has a chance I have one
of the games where I actually uploaded
on my channel I had a queen opponent
game where I was up a pawn against my
teammate and then I blundered the win
and then I didn't want to draw and then
I just lost the game so that was that's
the Queen Queen and planning games are
the worst so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it let's check out this
beautiful phone one more time it's just
a very very inspirational follow I could
just look at it you know just you know
hang it on my refrigerator is just very
very positive photo you know to two good
gentlemen just enjoying enjoying their
time so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it we're gonna show Magnus
versus eleven of course but this is the
game for for the first place so I
decided to show this one first I would
like to thank Shai cross and Adam Decker
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check too in my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see soon continuing the coverage of
the Grantchester checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and like I said do
check out the links in the description
below and be a part of the subscribers
video thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day